Priscilla first of all how are you I'm
okay thank you I'm good you've had a
kind of extraordinary few years really
um some great highs some terrible
lows and I've interviewed you various
stages in the last 15 years or so and
before I came today I was just wondering
actually genuinely how you would
doing well in all honesty um you know it
has been pretty T you know I lost my mom
then I lost my grandson and then I lost
my daughter so I don't know exactly how
to answer that because I have my good
days and I have my bad days so you know
you just you never know and uh it's
um how could I say it's
uh it's difficult it's difficult to wake
up in the morning and and not you know
have a call from my daughter or or
wonder how my grandson is doing it's
like a part of your not part but a large
part of your life is taken
away the particular difficulty for
someone like you is that you can't do
this privately that everything is
magnified on a global stage right and
there was a quote which really resonated
with me I suspect it will with you from
baz lurman who of course directed Elvis
the movie and he said there's the
Kennedy and there's the Presley
they are the royal families of America
and in different ways they both were as
Shakespeare says wedded to Calamity is
it genetic is it because they have such
high standards is it because the world
watches them maybe because to be
American royalty is not just to have
your country watch you to be American
royalty is to have the whole world watch
you did that resonate with you
absolutely
absolutely you know um when you're
living a life you know and I mean being
married to Elvis Presley you don't
really know what you're getting into
especially when you're younger and
um you know you have to adapt to not
really having your
privacy um things getting out that you
wish didn't um you start uh thinking my
gosh you know I I have to be careful you
know what I say or it'll be taken wrong
or they'll add on to it so it's it's a
it's been a journey there's no doubt
there's a movie now about
you your Center Stage it's your life
it's called
Priscilla and when they first air it at
the Venice Film Festival you were there
and at the end there's a very moving
clip as you get a standing ovation from
about 7 minutes yeah from an ecstatic
crowd and you're in tears at the
end what was it that moved you in that
moment for the uh the for the the movie
getting that kind of reception I never
you know when you have a movie that's
about
you um you never know how people are
going to take it um you never know if
they're going to understand it I mean
they have their own you know with all
this
people you know that's a big name it's a
big name
and I was happy because um
it had a standing ovation I was happy
for Sophia she was quite nervous about
it sopop Sophia Copa right I was nervous
too not knowing how people are just
going to you know not do anything and
just so very nice and get up and
leave um so it was a surprise to both of
us how well it was
received is it an accurate depiction do
you think not just of you but of your
relationship with Elvis I think so I
think she did a she did a you know I
mean she did some homework I mean she
and I we talked about it and um you know
living with Elis Presley people think oh
how wonderful that's great it's Elvis
Presley but I went through the ups and
downs with him in our very crucial part
of his life um you know his ups and
downs um his
struggles
uh you know his uh
fears so you know you when you're living
with someone so
famous uh and you've been through it
with them it's that part of privacy that
you're it's hard to give up it's hard to
share it's hard to you know I don't want
to give out too much because I want some
of that myself that's just for me and
actually one of the reasons it's reputed
that Elvis loved you so much was that
from the very first moments that you
were together even though you were very
young and you were at school and we'll
come to that
you never spoke about him to people
right you absolutely respected and
protected his privacy even though at the
time he's one of the biggest stars in
the world and that really endeared you
to him the fact that you safeguarded the
Privacy I did when I first started
dating him or let's say you know he
would call to to my parents to see if I
could um come over just on the weekends
you know maybe Friday maybe Saturday
that whole I mean part of my life was
um getting to know him but the question
was why
me why is he drawn to me why is he
asking my mother and father if it's okay
if you know I would go visit and when I
put all the pieces together it's because
I really I was The Listener I was the
one that he
trusted um more I think than
anyone
and I honored that and I would never
give that up um I never told kids at
school that I was seeing him no one even
knew because I valued that trust um and
why and I would ask the question why me
why does he trust me um I was the
listener he would tell me about how
upset he was with his father who was who
actually he lost his mother uh a year
before he went to the Army and then his
father met this woman who had three
children
and he couldn't believe his father I
couldn't believe yes that his father
would so soon start dating and falling
in love and then he would pour his heart
out uh to me get emotional about it
because he was so close to his mother so
I look at the trust Factor meant a lot
to him a lot and to this day you know
there are things I hold to my heart and
I won't give up you never bad mouth
Elvis I've noticed that about you your
entire life no you've never have even
though you got divorced and everything
else you've been an impeccable support
to him even decades after his death it
obviously matters to you a lot a lot he
was a very special human being and to be
put in the position that he was never
expecting to be as big as he came you
know he just loved his music he loved to
sing he loved to entertain people and
that's what he started out until much to
his surprise he was received so well and
I remember being in Las Vegas and it was
always a packed I mean literally he he
sold out every
night and he looked in the audience and
he'd see it full every single night and
then he'd go later on and start touring
and that would be sold out every night
and he said to me you know I see all
these people coming to see me and I
don't understand why am I to do and be
something else is there a message for me
that maybe I should be preaching maybe I
have a message for people and he would
bring out the Bible at night sometimes
and look and read and not that he
compared himself to Jesus in any way he
he read the Bible all the time it was
just it was just him thinking maybe I'm
here for another purpose a message to
give and people you know when I when I
have said that very rarely um it's
something that it weighed on him one of
the contentious points of the movie is
one of the contentious points about your
relationship with Elvis which is when
you met him you were 14 and he was 24
how do you think the movie deals with
that some people who've reviewed it say
well you can see there he's he's
grooming her um others saying that know
post me too he would have been cancelled
for this kind of thing what do you feel
about it because it was a different time
it was the early 60s the early 60s and
you know I I compare this to my mother
my mother my father was in the military
my mother would dress up for my father
every day when he came home from work
she was dressed up that was that and
women were that way we we were you know
not that it was just for our men but we
took care of ourselves and we wanted to
be um when I say we I I I include myself
um we respected my mother respected my
father uh and other women wore dresses
back in the day they did not wear pants
slacks
jeans uh so that was just the time it
was I mean you know Elvis was was um
like I said he was very unique but he
was uh I don't know about grooming me he
I didn't take it at that I never heard
the word I mean obviously it's all new
now but you know he loved to take me to
to um beautiful uh stores to buy me a an
outfit I didn't have any money I he
would take me you know to the movies
every night that's when you dressed up
and he wanted me to be to look good and
not feel bad that I had jeans or not
jeans but you know a little dress that
didn't really fit
uh for or be suitable for where we were
going so um so yes he would buy clothes
for me and and and love to and look at
when you see what he wore he would dress
up to a tea so he wanted to wanted me
also to be dressed up but people today
with the mindset of today will look back
and say it was inappropriate that he
would be with a girl of 14 what do you
say to people that think
I understand I understand but um I was
14 in Germany and um my I was uh there
was always people around um uh and our
talks were yes private but he never ever
ever was aggressive nor did he ever make
love to me um I was somehow like I said
earlier someone he trusted to talk to
and pour his heart out and famously
you only consumated your relationship on
your wedding night that's right in fact
that's when Lisa Marie was conceived
that's right that night and you were 21
I think when you got married mhm no one
would believe that but it's the honest
of God truth yeah I believe it yep I've
seen you say it before
yep in the movie again depending what
your mindset is I think you could either
say as some people have done that Elvis
comes off as kind of distant emotionally
abusive to a degree um a drug addict
obviously people knew that towards the
end of his life um quite a negative
characterization but other people have
said in the same light that you just did
about it that it was a different time
and that actually he was also coping
with the extraordinary pressures yes of
being the biggest superstar in the world
yes and that brings with it unique
challenges he had a lot on his shoulders
to take care of to do he had you know
films that he hated all of them actually
except the first two really yes he was
you know he felt that he was being a
joke you know to have this kind of on
the beach girls girls girls and that's
all really what hell Wallace gave him
Colonel Parker signed a five-year
contract with with Hal Wallace and uh
never cared about what kind of movies
they were Elvis was frustrated that the
fact that he couldn't get roles that he
wanted um and uh Colonel just didn't
understand his client at all what was he
like Colonel B yeah um colonel was he
like the Tom Hanks portrayal in the
movie uh somewhat but um Colonel I never
had a problem with colonel colonel was
different not being Colonel uh we would
go to his home in Palm Springs and visit
him um Elis would wanted to wanted to
see carinal and they talk a little bit
business and I'd be stuck with his wife
and didn't know what to say but um but
um there were times when Elis and him
would talk and they'd get along it's
just when Colonel Parker interfered with
Elvis's choice of songs um that's when
it really that's part of the movie and
when he's upset because colonel was you
know trying to change the music and
wanting him to sing a different song or
talk to a producer and said he should be
doing this when he got in Elvis's way
that's when Elvis would go to all all
out did you did you feel Elvis was a
controlling influence on you um
controlling I I don't think it was
controlling I never thought about it
being controlling no I don't
um the only the only thing that I can
think of is when he would appear in
Vegas is when he he would say you know
you can come on the
weekends um I had my daughter at the
time Lisa so um I didn't like leaving
her uh I had a nanny yes um but he would
say Well then why don't you just come on
the weekends or you know pick another
time because I was concerned about
leaving my daughter and he didn't really
want not that he didn't love children he
loved children but he didn't feel Vegas
was where you brought children which is
true I still think that too it's I mean
you know I'm not what I what I mean is
when when you're having big uh shows
like he had and kids would start crying
or whatever I just kind of yeah you
don't want to scream the baby El this
show exactly you were 16 when you first
went to graceand 17 17 MH I mean again a
crazy experience for a young teenage
woman to suddenly be propelled from a
very normal life into this do you
remember it vividly the the first few
experiences there well when um when I
first went to graand to visit it was in
June of 62 I believe and
um I I um no was 63 it was I was in
Vegas in ' 62 okay
63 Elvis um was there and he wanted uh
for me to close my eyes when they drove
up to the gate cuz I had heard about
grin he told me all about grain and I
would love grin it's so beautiful and I
mean he he he loved grin that was his
home and the first home he ever bought
so I closed my eyes and um he asked the
driver to have the gates open and you
could see the beautiful Gates and they'd
start they'd open up and the lights were
on the it was so beautiful I I more than
what I ever expected but he was so proud
of it and to not just to me to show
people and and to um taking them around
the house and the grounds and and it was
it was it was beautiful it was a nice
moment it was a magical place in many
ways and yet what comes through from the
movie is that he would go off and make
his movies and while he was away you
were often left for long periods of time
on your own in this extraordinary place
and but actually life there could be
quite dull mundane repetitive lonely I
mean uh sopia cppa she made lost in
trans and there's a little bit of that
vibe that comes through where you think
yeah okay you were you were with Elvis
Presley but life a lot of the time for
you was not wildly exciting at all there
was a lot of telephone calls right he
would always call me at 5:00 in the
evening and I would wait to phone call
every night yes and you'd be there ready
I'd be there by the
phone I was uh was it lonely for you or
not it was a bit lonely I I had no
friends I I made friends with his double
first cousin py I'm still friends with
her she's still with us thank goodness
um but she worked in the office so I
would go out in the office and talk with
her and of course the other secretary
that was there and CH chitchat until uh
Vernon would come in and tell me that
that I was um you know I was kind of
intruding on their time and what they're
doing and their work so he put a sign up
which is still there only people who
were basically are you know have to be
in the office so that's not exactly what
it says but um very close so yes it was
lonely and I went bowling with py um I
went to the movies um took care of
grandma talk with her for hours and
watch
television doesn't sound particularly
Showbiz no it's not
Showbiz but I I would just wait for him
to come home and and then life would
start life started when he came home and
there's this sort of sense you get in
the movie and you get it whenever you
read about Elvis you would know better
than anybody obviously when he walked
into a room energy levels through the
roof I mean he was Elvis presly the the
Charisma was just crazy even if he
wasn't in a great mood it was still
crazy this Charisma do you do you
remember that oh my God yes he'd walk
into the room and it's like wow I mean
he he didn't realize you know what he
had as as far as his appearance or what
he felt or his Charisma but um there was
a few times when he'd K around and he go
damn I'm
goodlooking kiddingly when he would be
in his his um bathroom and he'd be
getting ready to go somewhere but he had
a great sense of humor a great sense of
humor and I I treasure those days
sitting at the dining room table and I
was the only woman and um it be the guys
sitting around about six of us and we
would um laugh and talk and he ate late
hours um actually about 9:30 or so and
we watched Johnny Carson and as soon as
uh the monologue was over it's time to
go to the movies that he would rent a
theater um downtown so life was life was
fun when he was around he just there's a
lovely story that Kaylee spany tells who
plays you in the movie she was very
impressed to learn that you did Karate
to a pretty high level and you actually
used to for Elvis and his mates you
would perform your mov in addressing
heels mhm well he made me do that a
couple of times I remember Raquel Welch
came into the dressing room when he was
performing in Vegas and he'd be so proud
of me that I can learn that I learned
karate because he was he was you know he
was a black belt and he would say so you
know show show one of your moves to to
Raquel and I'm dressed up and I said you
do I have to do it right now and I'm in
my dress he goes no no no you can do
that back kick show how you do the pat
kick oh my God you still do it I can
still do it really yeah I can still do
it don't make me do it though this what
would it take to trigger a few karate
chops the wrong question a Karate
uniform um let's let's talk about you
you split from Elvis and you get divorc
from Elvis but you have
this little girl Lisa Mar she's your
child that you have with Elvis his only
child what was that relationship like
after the divorce between the three of
you would you say well I because when I
left I wanted I you know I he adored her
and I never wanted to take that away
from him so I made arrangements that on
Christmas or holidays or Easter that she
that he it was a point that that I would
send her to Gracin oh of course the
nanni was there with her I we bring her
there that he had time alone with her so
even in in uh Las Vegas the same thing I
I wanted them you know to be close which
they were and be was he a good father
despite all the problems he was having
he was as good a father as he could be
you know he was never around children
and you know it was he you know growing
up so he really honestly when he was she
was smaller he didn't quite know what to
do with her um but as as she got a
little bit older and a little bit older
and then she could travel you know to
visit him and be with him for at least 2
weeks you know when it was um like I
said Christmas or Easter or something
then he became closer to
her his death was something that shook
the entire world but for you and your
daughter it must have been a
particularly seismic shocking
moment devastating to get a call
absolutely devastating I had just talked
to him the night before
actually and I um no two nights before
and it to to get that call um Jo bazito
actually called me and said
s um Elvis is dead and he was already
emotional and
I just yelled you know I thought he was
kidding you know you you just never
imagine that that we would joke around
all the time and then when I found out
that you know it was true and I just
went to my bedroom and just stayed and
Joe said you send the plane for me the
private
plane and I just stayed in my room and
couldn't believe it and cried and I
don't
know it's it's interesting even though
this
is 50 years ago pretty much nearly yeah
but it still has a profound effect on I
can still hear Jo eso's words so oh this
is dead and that was like I couldn't I
just couldn't imagine him ever you know
especially you know his age and all
being so still so young and wanting to
do so much and had so much planned and
not having him not having him not
talking to
him um not having him be the father of
our child and what you know my big fear
was LE Lisa you know and how do I how do
I tell her and she was only nine at the
time I have a daughter of 11 I can't
imagine a harder conversation to have
right how how did you tell her well I
just told her we're going to Gracin and
we we're going to go see Daddy but Daddy
won't be you know Daddy will be
resting and she just asked me and she
goes well what resting I've never
actually told this before cuz it's been
hard but um I said well he's going to go
to sleep for a while and she goes will I
be able to see him and I said yes you'll
be able to see him you'll be able to see
him and then she sees him and uh I don't
think she really quite got it but uh
because she went out in the golf cart
and started uh she had a little friend
and driving in the golf cart and all
around the backyard of
graand so I don't it didn't really hit
her until later I would say I took her
to Europe actually
uh when I got back to uh LA because the
paparazzi was around my home and making
phone calls and trying to reach me and
that's what I didn't want her to see so
I took her with my sister and her and we
went to Europe for two weeks and I
wouldn't let her in some of the papers
at the airport they'd still they had
people selling the shock of him dying
they were selling the papers and I just
took everything and went the other way
and didn't want her to either you I
didn't I kept her from school and I
asked the teachers you know please don't
mention don't I don't want her I don't
want kids so difficult I mean I can't
even imagine because it was such a huge
story for the rest of the world but for
you this is just this is real life this
is your man that you loved still loved
still loved today still up today yep he
was like I said he was unique he was um
his personality was Unreal he was
caring
um he cared for people he had um he
wondered why him um and when I mean he
there's stories about him I don't know
if you ever heard the story about a
there was a black woman who was um
looking at a car on beill Street uh a
car dealership and he was looking and he
was just driving around and he saw her
looking in the in the windows at the new
cars that were there and he said told
Charlie to stop the car he stopped out
and he went over to the woman and he
goes boy those are nice cars and he said
oh yes sir they're beautiful look at
that and he goes what one do you like
and he she goes o I like that black one
right there you know that blue one right
there and he goes really yeah I kind of
like that too so then he takes her in
and they go in see the car and she he
says what do you think oh that's a
beautiful car you'll be good in that car
right he goes well just a minute he goes
and gets a the salesman he says give me
the keys to that car I'm getting it and
he gives the keys to her and that was a
beautiful blue catalac brand new that's
him that's what he would do anyone in
trouble he'd give them money anyone who
had you know a problem with anything
really you know and they couldn't afford
it even with some of the guys who needed
uh medical care he'd pay for it when
you've watched Elvis the movie in now
Priscilla and it's made you revisit all
of these times that you had with him do
you have any part of you that thinks if
only I'd done this this or this things
could have turned out differently you
know I don't know I don't think so
because I I really um you know I gave my
all to him I I you know I couldn't I
couldn't change his mind I mean he was
strong minded you know when he wanted he
thought something or he wanted to share
things with people he was very he was
very excited about you know getting
people gifts um didn't like receiving
them but giving he was a giver but I I
look back and I mean we still had a
relationship that's the best thing
really but I think he he loved you and
you loved him till the day he died
that's clear yes it was an extraordinary
love story he would call me all the time
and it was so funny because whoever he
was with he would usually go into his
bathroom to make the phone calls so they
couldn't e yeah and I I've never really
shared that at all actually but yes he
would either that or go out to the
office and call and um that that was
kind of fun do you remember your last
conversation with
her my last conversation yes was when
Lisa was coming home that she needed to
come home because school was starting
and Lisa Lisa was there during that time
yeah that was it it's very I mean it's
it's very poignant for me to talk to you
who's in the end you're you're a woman
that has this extraordinary life and had
this extraordinary relationship with
this man but here we are I think he died
in
1977 and here we are in
2023 and I can see the effect he still
has on you just on a personal human
level there's nothing tabloid or
anything about this this was a real
visceral love affair between you I miss
him I miss him very much yeah I miss his
words I miss his love I miss his laugh I
miss his energy I miss the fun times I
think you know you don't really realize
the fun times that you're having until
you go back and you look at your albums
and your pictures and you go oh my God
we had so much fun we did so much
and uh you know it's still it's still
there is there a song that whenever you
hear
it you think for whatever reason there's
one song of his that memories really mhm
yeah press between the pages of my mind
yeah yeah I do I don't listen to them
that songs very often because it just
you know I go into you know another
place but I I know sometimes I I am a
little
um surprised at myself that I still get
emotional and um I still I you know love
is still there it's amazing really some
people many people I think might go
through their entire lives without ever
having that
feeling well I think too I think too is
because he's so present he's still so
present he's still so a
affects people but he you know it it's
like when I go to Vegas sometimes you
know I think my God that you go to the
Hilton Hotel you see these big showrooms
you go if people it's never Vegas has
never been the same I think I don't
think there was only one Elvis I mean
they there are lots of Pretenders to the
crown but there's never been any one
like him right since he died it's true
you know in the movie um Sophia did um
which he was angry you know with Colonel
Parker and you know yes he was angry and
yes he threw the chair or whatever but
he he would when he was angry he would
go especially with Colonel Parker he
would go into that moment you know
because he just felt that colonel was
you know colonel was really uh deceiving
him in many ways that he's wasn't giving
him what he wanted and yet he would talk
behind his back let's say to the whoever
was uh doing the albums or whatever the
sound people even um you would have
personal relations personal
relationships with them so I think that
I my memories
go right to that and write you know in
the moment and saving the movie was hard
and that I was never I mean Sophia was
never making that movie to show at the
bad side of of us that was a real moment
when he Wass with Colonel Parker and it
showed that he yes he had a temper yes
that's you know what he felt you know at
that moment but that didn't mean he was
like that all the time hardly but he
knew what he wanted and he didn't want
you know someone to go against him when
he knew and he did his instincts were
absolutely right yes absolutely right so
you know people walk out oh my God he's
got oh my God he was no he was a human
being and he had feelings and yes he had
a temper he didn't show it that much but
when he did he had every reason
to when you when you out in the about
when you get on planes or wherever you
may go how do people react to
you they're friendly very friendly and
you know they ask me for my
autograph which sometimes you know
surprises me but um but they even
recognize me to be honest but uh uh yes
someone told me that often they'll
they'll clap yes some s they people do
that's amazing I know I know just just
applaud because you are still American
royalty well you know I happen to be
married to someone very very famous but
I don't really look at it that way but I
can see with him but um but people
people have
been great I really I can't I have no
complaints they've been very I've been
very fortunate in that there's a a
horrible irony in many ways that it it
was literally at the moment that the
Elvis movie was being fated at the
Golden Globes and you attended with Lisa
Mar that within 48 Hours of that she
incredibly sadly died in her mid
50s what was I I've read an account that
you both went to chatow Mar Mo and you
were laughing together as a mother and
daughter um and everything seemed fine
and then she suddenly said to you that
she was having these crippling stomach
pains yeah did you did you fear there
was something very bad happening well I
I she didn't look well that night and I
was
concerned and uh she asked Jerry
Schilling who is a good friend of mine
very one of my best friends if not the
best friend um if he she could if he
could hold her her heels were high and
and she's worn them before and I thought
is she okay she didn't really look
looked that okay she looked very frail
so I let that go and then uh we watched
the show and um we had a few laughs and
and we were all excited about Austin
Butler and you know bz and you know the
movie went so well we're proud of them
and you know and then we started to go
and she said mom you want to go to Sho m
m and have a drink and I said sure I had
gone in my own car and she came had her
own car cuz she lived in Calabasas she
and uh let's go and we get out and we
get down to the we both had our high
heels and both of us tripped at the one
staircase we started laughing and and
giggling and then we went there and sat
down and um you Mom I have to go my my
stomach really hurts and I go of course
you okay she goes yeah yeah just I
really have to go and I go okay okay
we'll get the cars now and then we walk
toward the car and I I hugged her and
and uh she went her way and I went mine
and that was that hug was the last was
the last hug I gave her and it's still
shocking that um you know I don't we
don't have her
I I got that call from her um ex-husband
Danny that uh you know I need that I
need to go to the hospital see Lisa that
she's in the hospital
and then I thought oh my God you know
this is not the first time but I never
thought that it was the
last and it was too late you you didn't
see her it was too late oh you're still
alive
yeah I mean they say that it's the worst
possible thing to lose a
child I I given your relationship how
close you were what you'd all what you'd
been through as a family it must have
been particularly painful unbearable
well it is it was unbearable you know I
lost my mother I lost my grandson and I
lost my
daughter and um losing van was was
was that was the hardest thing for her
losing Ben cuz he took his own life he
took his own life and he was I mean he
was the love of her life life that child
she adored him she would do anything for
him
anything and um we were in Memphis we
sitting up in the suite and she said
mom you know I don't know I don't know I
don't know if I want to be here and I go
what are you talking
about you know my Ben and she'd go on
about Ben and how she is still grieving
and this was a couple a couple of months
before that she was feeling almost
suicidal herself I think
so she really she was almost like I she
wanted to go earlier but the the Twins
were still
young or to Young let's put it that way
so Twins were what
13 it's so sad M I know don't talk
anymore
can you stop the camera
please sorry about that no no of course
be completely understandable
um Lisa of course at one stage was
married briefly to Michael Jackson right
arguably after Elvis the other great pop
icon has ever been
were you concerned mhm about that mhm
very yeah and I was honest with
her you know she told me she was seeing
him
and you know she was seeing him for a
little bit actually and then I remember
being in Hawaii and she was we were
walking together on the beach and she
said Mom I'm really concerned and I go
this is while they were married and said
that you know I'd never see him I go
what do you mean you never see him he's
always
gone I go where does he go and she goes
I don't know I don't know where he goes
he'll call me maybe 3 or 4 days later I
said well don't you ask him where he's
going he goes he just said you know he's
around has things to
do and I always felt that you
know Michael you know Jackson Lisa
Presley and he he you know loved Elvis
or respect did all this so I always felt
excuse me that having the name you know
um be associated with the name with his
daughter yeah I did I was concerned I
told her thought maybe that was his main
motivation I did did you I
did I mean I I I know he was a bit
fearful of me and she told me you know
he's afraid of you and I go what is he
afraid of me for why is he afraid why
should he be afraid of me and she goes I
don't know he doesn't think you'll like
him I said I've hardly talked to him cuz
he always hides right we were at the
peab Buddy Hotel in Memphis and um I
went to see her at her suite and and
we're talking and then all of a sudden I
said well where's Michael said he's
getting dressed and I go okay so I he
pops out really quickly to get his hat
that was left on the end table and then
rushes back and closes the door I said
God do I scare him that much
was it was it do you think because he
knew you saw through him a bit yeah I
think I think he's I I think he was
quite smart and I think he did yeah I
think he did but um she then told me
that you know they were getting that she
wanted a divorce and then the rest is
history
yeah the don't get me wrong I thought he
was very talented um truly talented and
but I never really got to know him and
you would have preferred him not to
marry your daughter yeah I just because
I felt that he was so intrigued about
Elvis and you know just you know here's
Lisa
and is he with her because she's Lisa or
because she's a Presley I think more
because she was a Presley
yeah after Lisa died it was widely
reported obviously that there was a
dispute between you and uh Riley her
daughter and it's all been settled oh
yeahh and Riley gave an interesting
interview to Vanity Fair and I thought
there was some there were some wonderful
lines there I thought because it really
resonated with me for any F any family
particularly a family like yours which
has all the added outside pressures and
of course huge amounts of money with the
estate and everything else um and she
said when my mom passed there was all of
Chaos in every respect of Our Lives
everything felt like the carpet had been
ripped out and the floor had melted from
under us everyone was in a bit of a
panic to understand how we move forward
and it took a minute to understand the
details of the situation because it's
complicated we're a family but there's a
huge business side of our family so I
think that there was Clarity that needed
to be had and Clarity is being had and
they then asked are things with Grandma
happy and she said a really interesting
response things with Grandma will be
happy they've never not been happy she
said I'm trying to think of a way to
answer it not a 20-minute conversation
there was a bit of an upheaval then she
said this about you she's a beautiful
woman and she was a huge part of credit
my grandfather's Legacy in graceand it
was very important to her he was a love
of her life anything that was suggest
otherwise in the Press makes me sad
because at the end of the day all she
wants is to love and protect graand and
the Presley family and the Legacy that's
her whole life it's a big responsibility
she try to take on none of that stuff
has ever really been a part of our
relationship prior she's just been my
grandma and I thought that was actually
a lovely way to describe it yeah I I
never read that wow wow I'm got to cry
again yeah how does that make you feel
oh my God I love her I mean I've we have
always gotten along you know I think it
was the press that really started all
this and you know it's like like
everything else they don't give you you
know they don't when something comes out
like like yes it was a little bit of um
trying to figure out the will trying to
figure out you know like you normally do
but Riley and I have always been close I
mean at the center of it it seemed quite
straightforward that Lisa Marie had
changed her will but hadn't actually
told you and in changing it she'd made
the executiv or Trustees of the will
were to beat her children which is
perfectly understandable absolutely you
just didn't know so when she suddenly
dies tragically young and this all comes
out out you just were caught blindsided
that's what it seemed to me that's all
it was that was all it was you know and
I think Riley will be great um she's you
know asked me a few things about what to
do and where we'll we'll talk about like
I want to I want to help her like with
Gracin I mean she has her own career as
well and doing so well with her she's
very talented she's so talented so I
mean you're an incredibly talented fan
aren't you I mean putting aside all the
drama and the heartache and all the
other stuff underpinning it a lot of
very talented people thank you in your
family thank you I think so as well even
Ben was was quite talented as well and
he had dreams but um but uh with Riley
um I told her anything she needs to know
about graet about Elvis more so about
Elvis because you know she never really
took a part of of of going to graceand
only on special times of whether me
Christmas or you know we'd all go for I
don't know for some occasion not that
many times but uh I want her you know to
know a lot about Elvis and um I'll
probably you know help her in that way
she was asked in the interview about
this stuff that have been gossiped about
let's put it like that that there may be
some issue about whether you would one
day be buried with Elvis and graceand
Ben is obviously there Lisa Marie's
there now she said as far as she was
concerned absolutely do you want to
clear that up I mean how are your
feelings about that well I because my
feelings are great I mean that's you
know what what I want and wanted you'd
like to be buried next well yes yes and
that will happen
yes I think people would like that at
least right now well no obviously I
don't want to be no no I mean let's hope
it's a very long way down the line but
but that's that's settled that's nothing
to be no no
um um I think you know with Riley She's
she's got a great head on her shoulders
she really is and and we've had many
talks um I trust her I I I believe she's
capable of taking taking on some
especially some you know some things
that Grays son when we have to be there
in person together or just her and and
but after all you turned Grace I me it
was losing money it was was basically
going out of business you turned it
almost single-handedly actually I mean
you had help but it was your driving
force that's turned into a100 million a
year business I mean it was an amazing
achievement that you did there I know I
sometimes look back at how in the world
did I do this how did you do it be proud
red up my S would be proud of you yeah I
just rolled up my sleeves and it said it
has to be done because it was I was um
uh I had two had uh Elvis's um
bookkeeper and his attorney the three of
us were
Executives they didn't know anything
about Elvis I didn't know his you know
what he wanted what he didn't want they
just took care of
business and I they came to me this is
three years after uh we got
grin and one of them came to me and said
Priscilla we're in dire need of money we
don't have it we have to sell grin and I
just looked at him and I said that will
never happen he goes but we're out of
money I said that will never happen and
then I left and then I just rolled up my
sleeves and I went out and asked people
who you know as people that I knew I'm
looking for someone to help me do this
how do I open up the home where do I go
where do I go who do I go to how do I do
it and then I just met with some top
people
um uh actually Peter ubera I don't know
you know who he is yeah okay Peter yov
who was actually um supporting the
Olympics back in the day and I thought
oh wow you know he took on something I'm
going to talk and have a meeting with
him and he told me that's not really
what he does but recommended somebody
and I went to that person and they
weren't the right ones either so I went
to um I had a friend who said you know
there's someone that lives in Kansas
City that I think could be a a great
match for you and this this was Morgan
Maxfield and um I went to I met him in
Nashville actually I told him I wanted
to open gron I need to help and then
long story
short we went to uh Disneyland when uh
Disney World was opening and I met some
people there but that wasn't I don't
want to
Disneyland and that's not the case at
all so um we still talked and we he said
listen we we we can I'm got have a
private plane just my plane and we're
going I forgot where are we even going
and I go um okay uh I was supposed to be
on that plane I said I can't go long
story short Jack Soden who uh I I hired
was his guy in other words he worked for
him Morgan well Morgan plane crashed and
um everyone they died all of them there
about six I think or one two three I
don't know it doesn't matter right now
but Jack sodin I talked to cuz he went
with us to uh to Disneyland at that time
and we went to uh Nashville to look at
some other places and I said Jack I'm
coming to you because you were with us
and you know what I need and you know
the talks that we had I I want you to be
the CEO of graceand and he goes you know
prisilla that's not really what I do and
I go yeah but just smart I know you can
do it and uh sure enough he's still
there amazing he's still there and this
this huge business but is also
absolutely in the spirit of Elvis
because it's being driven by someone
that knew what his Spirit was right do
you do you ever go to Grayson oh yes of
course what do you feel like when you go
I feel like I never left really I feel
like I never left I'd go in the house
and sit in the living room and look
around and go my God so many memories
here oh my God I can listen I can hear
Elvis's laughter I can see him playing
the piano after we'd come home from from
the theater or the movies um and we'd go
in in the in the um piano room and he'd
go straight to the piano and I'd sit on
a couch and he'd start singing gospel
music that's all all there
still in the Vanity Fair interview that
Riley did she said this about uh Lisa
Marie her mom the life she had wasn't
easy the treachery she enjoed but like a
real love and real friend she definitely
had some great friends and relationships
but I don't think she ever really had
then she tells her people would just
coming for her since she was born
wanting something from her not being
totally authentic she had to develop a
thick skin she was a very powerful
presence extremely loving extremely
loyal sort of a lioness a fierce woman
and a really wonderful mother I think
that would be my summary because I'm her
daughter she was the best mom when I
read that I mean you could almost say
exactly the same about you H
wow interesting um well that's a a
compliment yeah thank you it is I just
think it's to try and exist in the
Goldfish bowl that you've had to do that
LE had to do all the family have had to
do right you have to have a thick skin
you have to be a bit of a lioness and
none of us are thick skinned than we
have to be right it's true it is true I
mean I chose to be very private I really
I really um I'm not out there that much
I enjoy my friends my my family what I
have left and and um live live a normal
life how do you feel now we're coming to
the end of this actually what been
extraordinarily revealing interview far
more than I anticipated me too how do
you feel I don't know maybe I talk too
much I don't know I'm a little nervous
um well I don't know I um I've talked
about things I've never talked about
before I'm at a time in my life where
I'm willing to share and you um I trust
you you and I've always liked your you
know your interviews that you've had
with different people and um I hope it
comes out okay I'm sure it will I think
people will feel the same way that I did
which is you're a remarkable person who
had a remarkable life and I'm I'm glad
you have a movie now which is about you
and your life because I think in many
ways it's hugely significant and has
been hugely significant to not just
Elvis when he was alive but also
preserving his Legacy since he died I
think you've played such a massive part
in that and that's one of the reasons he
remains today so revered I think is
because the work and determination
you've had to keep the Elvis flag flying
and I hope this movie I mean I don't
want anyone I know there's a few
comments on him being angry my God he's
a human being he's a human being and an
artist and an artist absolutely but he
you know with with Elvis was I I've
never met anyone like him and I don't
think I ever will again ever he had a
biggest heart he had a great sense of
humor had a lot of love um he could be a
little kid you know when when he wanted
to he loved to be babied um and he just
I I there's no one like him and the fact
that he still has fans he would never
believe that he would never believe it
ever that he still has fans and they're
everywhere and they're every everywh but
he um I there'll never be anyone like
him
ever Priscilla what a privilege to sit
with you for the last hour thank you
very much for being so open with me I
appreciate it thank you thank
you